c'est toi c'est quand même assez
étonnant se trouvait c'est une
admiratrice à vous
je trouve c'est quand même étonnant se
trouvait rue cambon avec vous et pensez
qu'il ya une autre coco chanel à
broadway qui est katherine hepburn mais
ya une chose qui a toujours étonné les
gens à propos du show ce n'est pas vous
vous n'aimez pas faire les costumes de
théâtre parce que cecil beaton qui les a
faits mais parce que ça m'embête c'est
pas mon métier j'ai travaillé les
structures plus les costumes de théâtre
vous en avez déjà les terrains brun et
gris pour leur faire titre a su marquer
ce qui aurait fait la corruption est
limité grâce au pack office
on peut plaire à tellement de moudre
quand on traverse étaient présentes
il ya une grosse différence entre un
costume de théâtre et une robe d'une
robe de ville oui il est rentré faire
n'importe quoi elle avait convié jean
ridicule au ch sont bien amusant je ne
fais jamais rien de ridicule
c'est pas le style moi j'ai trouvé un
style bonne fois pour toutes à sion et
il le savait les robes sont pas des
modèles trois jours parce qu'il ya
quelques coutumes ou pouvons dire trois
jours après son des mots de mon cher
possible ça
et catherine album ne vous ressemble pas
au départ et j'ai vu les photos c'est
hallucinant la ressemblance est une
femme actrice ous avez vous douté même
pas il a appris à chanter cette femme
qui serait fashion week n'a même pas
pensé que la même la voir elle
travaillait pour la banque qui avait
quatre mois qu'il travaillait pour voir
si elle pouvait sortir quelque chose
parce que ça l'embêtait dédoubler et le
physique même mot les photos que j'ai vu
c'est vous enfin c'est ça qui vous
prouve qu'elle est une bonne actrice
je voudrais des fiches n'aime pas ça
vous permettez je vais m'asseoir à côté
de vous sur l'escalier puis nous allons
regarder la collection très bien vous
voulez bien
oui bon alors on y va
collection printemps-été 70 qui débute
avec des tailleurs de tweed aux
quadrilles et fondus des écossais de
rose de beige ou de brens mademoiselle
chanel fidèle à la longueur s'arrêtant
amis genou propose une collection sobre
dépouillé fort élégante d'ailleurs
quadrillé rouge et blanc veste et jupe
portefeuille bordé de rouge bordure
marines et blanches pour le tailleur de
lainage blanc impression marine
créée nouveau le tailleur à l'ong basque
blanc aux rayures irrégulière
très élégant tailleur noir porté sur une
tunique de soie blanche et noire
l'abbé gonzague à caen pour l'après midi
robe de soie blanche à pois noirs jupes
plissées robes de soie marine jupes à
plis et chender
pour le cocktail robe très vaporeuse en
mousseline imprimée plissée du haut en
bas
la robe de mousseline avec colruyt
smoke in de la meilleure sur robes
droites
rv entièrement patinoire à l'ampleur
basse
virevoltante la robe du soir en organdi
de soie de jersey lamé or le deux pièces
parée d'un collier et d'une ceinture
noire et or ruchers boas sur robes
scintillantes framboise à volants de
mousseline noire
la cat board et le rucher et la robe
longue
c'est robes d'organdi blanc terminait
cette très belle collection